how many auditions did you have for that
for for lonesome for Will and Grace was
about six six in front of the studio the
network yeah it started with just the
writers and I I kind of knew after that
first audition that I was their pick but
then it was it was it was weirdly before
Christmas and
um pilot season didn't usually start
till late January early February so it
just felt too early and I kind of backed
away and I don't know it was just it
just it took a long time and then by the
time I had the role it was another month
before Deborah Messing
came in they always wanted her but she
wasn't available and I read with a whole
bunch of women it was a long process had
Max and David done a a series before
they had done Boston Common it was
called Boston Common that wasn't the
Shatner one no that was awesome yeah
Boston combo just I guess just like
school right and it was Anthony
um I forget his name
um Daniels
I'm sorry that's terrible
very squeaky that made me uncomfortable